so your unlike talking you don't
approach these like architecture you
don't have this entire like all the
details and manuals and glossary is laid
out there no I have I am some of that
but less much less than you would think
it's it's a much more organic process
I've often said that they're writers are
of two types there there is the
architect which is one type and the
architect as with designing a building
lays out the entire novel ahead of time
he knows how many rooms there will be
and what a roof will be made of and how
high it will be and where the plumbing
will run and that where the electrical
outlets will be in each room and all of
that stuff before he drives the first
nail everything is there in the
blueprint and then there's the gardener
who like digs a hole in the ground and
puts in the seed and waters it with his
blood and he sees what comes up
now the gardener knows certain things
it's he's not completely ignorant he
knows whether he planted an oak tree or
an ear of corn or a cauliflower so he
has some idea of the shape but a lot of
it depends on the wind and the weather
and and how much blood he gives it a so
forth so I think all writers are no one
is purely an architect no one is purely
a gardener in terms of writers but many
writers tend to one side or the other
and I'm very much more a gardener as
indeed was was Tolkien I mean for all
his the architecture he did on like the
similarly on which he began before World
War one he was he started learning rings
thinking he was writing a sequel to The
Hobbit and it would be another
children's book about the you know the
adventures of a couple hobbits stealing
something and it obviously grew into
something much larger than he ever
expected and you know he later said the
tale grew in the telling and that's a
line I've often had cause to quote
myself because my tale has grown into
telling many many times